[Music]
today the Attorney General Bill Parr had
strong words about Robert Muller's
upcoming testimony questioning why the
Democrats are even holding a hearing
with the former special counsel let's
listen it seems to me the only reason
for doing that is to create some kind of
public spectacle and if Bob decides that
he doesn't want to be subject to that
the department certainly back and
tonight Congressman Peter King New York
is warning quote severe serious abuses
by the FBI and CIA in the Russia probe
are going to come out we've been saying
that for two plus years joining us now
Fox News contributor former congressman
trey Gowdy you know what they have
always liked about you is when you dig
in god help whoever's on the other side
you're as a prosecutor you never lost
the case correct I've never won world
with mark with my wife so that's okay
that's a good line all right but it's 30
years worth of losses i I've watched you
in these hearings at times and I know
what you're capable of so now we'll try
and look back and give us bring us into
what what's really happening in your
view we got the inspector general
you got the comments of the Attorney
General you got Mullen testifying which
I think will backfire then you got
Durham he's seeing steel all these
people coming out last minute on FISA
abuse what do you see happening a couple
of things I think the Attorney General's
right the the hearing next week Muller
will be a Carville it'll be a freak show
think back to March of 2017 Sean when
when Devon noonas had a public hearing I
love Devon but public hearings I don't
turn out well no matter who calls them
Devon called a public hearing had Jim
Comey and Mike Rogers a hundred times
the witness said I cannot answer that
question in this forum you would think
the media would say that was a waste of
everybody some don't ever do that again
they love it they love it because what
Adam Schiff and swallow well and the
others did is read newspaper articles
that contain classified information only
for the witness that then have to say I
can't comment on that in this setting
that's what's going to happen next week
Muller's reports
he's not going to deviate from the four
corners of that report but that will not
keep House Democrats from asking if the
focus will be on the question not the
answer
warlords the other thing that's going on
but I love Peter King but Republicans
have got to get better at not always
promising what's getting ready to come
look at what already exists look at what
Horowitz found struck and page with a
historic level of bias you have a
dossier that was used in a court
pleading that was not verified you have
Steele who is defrocked as a source but
yet continued to provide information to
the world's premier law enforcement
agency and you got a DOJ senior official
and Bruce or who is in the chain of
evidence from the from fusing GPS to the
DOJ we shouldn't have to promise
anything else that ought to be enough
for my fellow citizens to say you know
what some mate right well who authored
to the Muller report when did he know
that there was no collusion how was it
he had time for taxi cab medallions
you're a prosecutor this prosecutorial
discretion it's used every day but he
had time for taxi medallions fara abuse
let's see
loan applications and taxes how did he
not have time for a dirty dossier
I'd like that question answer from
Russia I think what he's going to say I
think what he's gonna say on that and
Johnny Radcliffe and I were discussing
it over the weekend I think what he's
gonna say is that's not what right what
Robert Stein asked me to do I did what
what the acting DOJ AG asked me to do
which is look at go back to Rods memo
what did Russia do in 2016 and then a
specific reference to the Trump campaign
I think that smaller's out his out on
when did you know there was no collusion
is going to be when we interviewed the
last witness
so I Muller yeah mother doesn't want to
come he doesn't want to come because
he's not going to deviate from his
report what what you're gonna get are
these incendiary questions about
obstruction and impeachment you're not
gonna learn anything next Wednesday that
you don't already know it's just gonna
be great flow I suspect he's gonna have
a hard time answering how he didn't that
hang out
one candidate paid for Russian lies and
it became the basis of a FISA warrant
how did that not become an influence in
the 2016 election but taxi medallions
did I'd like an answer to that question
I hope somebody can get that asking
answered in five minutes there's not
much that I'll unlock the mystery over
the bottom Mahler's nine and a half
minutes was not exactly stellar and I
think the Attorney General graciously
bailed him out with a joint statement
that's a guess on my part I hope I'm
wrong I just oh the next wins who's
gonna help anybody figure out how what's
been going on you're pretty slide
everything Horowitz and Durham will buy
all day tomorrow
Muller is all right trey Gowdy Thank You
South Carolina tonight we appreciate